o gato foi o júlio brincou antes de
fecharem os olhos no primeiro momento eu
vou pedir mesmo isso e vou só largar
esse microfone um pouquinho pra que
vocês imaginem algo junto comigo
qual é o que evoca vocês houve uma
funcionalidade como essa aqui
vocês viram paisagens vocês pensaram
pessoas se pensar em animais vocês
pensaram numa forma de ser
muitas formas de ser e de resto em só o
brasil que vocês pensarem
mas até por isso eu não estou aqui para
fazer uma palestra
eu vou fazer uma palestra uma batalha
vou fazer uma palestra por que muitos de
vocês me conhecem sabem eu tenho uma
referência mas o que é uma referência
uma referência a um grande pensador um
grande escritor um grande músico chamado
ao varejo campanha a gente merecer ele
seja nosso também agente disco todo o
sotaque brasileiro sem problema ataualpa
eo pânico é as duas coisas é todas essas
coisas todas as pronúncias mundo 60
trabalho pode um time que não atahualpa
yupanqui aquele cara duas semanas
aquele cara disse assim encham a minha
boca de areia imagem viva
não sei vocês mas eu comi um bolinho de
barro quando era criança por causa dos
meus irmãos sempre é por causa dos
irmãos quando a gente é o menor não
porque a gente é meio a meio novinho em
pouco eu comer um bolinho de areia terra
pensando que era chocolate eu acho que
encheu minha boca de areia vão voltar
para o japão
encheu minha boca de areia se querem
calar a minha voz não é que aflige
dormir por isso a flecha já está no ar
a flecha já está no ar para encher se de
sol
o que eu tento fazer é deixar você assim
assim disparar flechas
se eu tiver força pra isso sim tomara
que vocês a porta e sol e calor
vocês a essas flash mas o que eu posso
fazer
sou radialista que sou um artista é
distribuir um pouco as flechas nos
grandes idéias alheias baixas
importantes
os grandes não estou falando em nome
falando de gente como teve aqui hoje
está aqui hoje
todos os três dias que são realmente
grandes lembram aquela algo pode até
usar kiko por razões hoje esportivas mas
aquela arma medieval e desenvolver o
arco era mais ligada com a conta pode
chamar de festa mas que pode chamar
também de palestras é por isso que eu
não faço palestra eu faço palestras e
vejam as flechas e eu espero que vocês
possam terão aportar com algum sol com
uma luz ao calor a essas flashes mas
antes eu sou artista como artistas
obrigado a evocar o traje
por sorte não vou voltar atrás para
todos vocês pela minha estatística
pessoal já meio antiga foi votar o
trágico para menos da metade de vocês
hoje uma palavra curta renal
nestes dias
essa palavra que vota o traje de
voto não é isso que eu quero fazer
são paulo de futebol
os que são rio grandenses aqui a gente
já vai ver porque eu tô dizendo
riograndense não gaúchos que são rio
grandenses aqui já ouviram autoridade
já o rio grande do sul vive uma grande
realização
nós somos maragatos e chimangos nós
somos colorados ou gremistas nós somos
tal qual partido político
nós somos maniqueístas nós somos
incapazes do martins
nós somos incapazes do meio termo da
mudança de opinião da gradação fazer uma
pergunta pra você você se senta em cima
quando vocês vêem o evento como esse
vocês acham que nós tem aquela palha
nós somos assim
é disso que quero falar para vocês é
muito bonita a maior parte das pessoas
aqui tenha falado em histórias de
superação contemporâneo mas a gente tem
que superar muitas coisas que são da
história são ancestralidade são antigas
a superação também nos exige militar
neste tipo de operação no rio grande do
sul
toda a nossa mitologia a respeito de nós
próprios
evoca uma figura e essa figura foi
cuiabá hoje o gaúcho tem apenas um
chamado gaúcho original
o gaúcho quem foi afinal de contas quem
é esse cara é um cara que no fim do
século 17 dirão uns até o fim do século
19 quase viram outros mas certamente com
todo o miolo do século 18 no meio foi
viver se afastou da sociedade colonial e
foi viver do exagero de gato que havia
nos nossos campos por necessidade porque
não bastar dos filhos de espanhol e
português com índia genética já mostrou
isso
sempre pelo lado feminino nos palcos
usuários claro do que imagina isso pela
forma como se deu a conquista era sempre
assim não os documentos mostram que
moços jovens de boa família na época em
que dizia edital está em fase final
o outro é filho de alportel de altura de
alguém se nota que gente da nobreza
crioula gente bem assentada na vida
colonial também foi vivendo esses caras
também foi viver de comer aqueles ela
sobra e sobra foi introduzido o gado com
várias correntes aqui a gente pode citar
no rio grande do sul
as missões jesuíticas que depois foram
achatadas tacadas e se cadu ficou por aí
numa terra em divisa cujo limite ainda
não era claro com flagrada produzindo
produzindo 10 na melhor passagem do
mundo
excelentes condições climáticas
predadores e suficientes para que deve
ter aumentado muito a população de onças
de cuba é bem gordos aquela terneira
daqueles bons velhos mas não davam conta
pensar que essa proliferação o índio
também não deu falta dessa proliferação
e ficou essa sobra que não se conta aos
milhares se quanto aos milhões de gado
por esses campos
esses caras foram viventes antes de
dizer como eram esses caras e como eu
acho que geram deixou lembrar vocês
sabem esse mito a partir do gaúcho e
depois resultou nessa confusão é usar
isso como gentílico chamar todo mundo
nasce o rio grande do sul gaúcha sempre
falando no assunto ficou um pouco
confuso
esse mito tenho uma força muito grande
na literatura as do rio grande do sul
pântano literário uma organização século
19 isso até hoje
dani também pela política sempre prever
a data com essa literatura com esse
intelectual pois bem justamente na época
isso não é por acaso daí aquela velha
história da invenção das tradições érico
eric hobsbawn enfim justamente na época
em que esse personagem verdadeiro real
histórico e sociológico está
desaparecendo começa essa exaltação
todas as nossas qualidades toda a nossa
maneira de ser parte daquela personagem
aquela figura que a gente conhece os
efeitos que esteve com as pessoas que
vem por exemplo de países europeus
correndo pra se a gauchão mas é possível
porque não tem legitimidade e garantiram
o seu dinheiro de volta
muito bem acontece algo no meio do
século 20 que é o tradicionalismo gaúcho
e pega isso tudo potencializa tem que
estar mais ou menos a cara que nós
conhecemos o certo
esse cara podia ser uma única lista a
digital grená lista será que ele saiu da
sociedade colonial que era isso era
brutal para tentar reproduzir pela ética
no campo do evento é 20 amigos pra mim
em absoluto quando esse time toma o
gaúcho libertário caráter libertário da
hoje se fazem sobre coisas verdadeiras
esse cara era um time mas vamos falar um
pouco da onde eles capô que ele fugia e
ali estava o medo
ali estava
ou não é desertor de uma força regular
ali estavam os desertores muitíssimos e
documentado
ali estavam caras extraídos de corsários
e piratas
a gente vê um preparo lindo na cabeça de
um cavalo abala o corpo para o brasil
eles estão nós de marinheiro de 600 anos
e palavras negras e palavras indígenas
por favor comidas do próximo ano
esse cara então reunir todo mundo ia
da palavra da moda verdadeira não deve
deixar de ser dita universidade já que
não era esse o cara capaz de distinguir
aqueles tempos quando a sociedade
colonial castigava fisicamente as
crianças os soldados marinheiros quando
a sociedade colonial promovia execuções
públicas como um show uma quermesse toda
todo mundo ia ver quando uma questão
entre 22 amigos era resolvida um duelo à
parte e quando por favor nós pensamos
quando mais grassou a coisa mais
violenta da história ocidental sob certo
aspecto é o santo ofício da santa
inquisição e o bárbaro o cara terrível
porque os quadros não pode ser o marco
seu prejuízo era game que saiu lá
ninguém não é o que os cronistas os
cronistas quase todo o século do cenário
dos viajantes que chegaram para a equipe
dizem por exemplo nicolau 3 disse gaúcho
não tem da moral se não as noções mais
lugares que ser agressivo mas a gente
pensando hoje
é a diferença a seguir dez mandamentos
de uma constituição de 1 600 artigos
esses caras
a arquitecta lhe não só que de resto as
condições eram muito menos entre eles a
violência infinitamente infinitamente eu
e um amigo e elas tomavam vinho uma
conferida
e aí pagou pago a não sei lembrando que
a bagagem então vamos jogar o primeiro
foi o primeiro portátil outro aquele
cortado pagaria saiu abraçado e amigos
alguém olhar e ver gente bonita da
sociedade colonial
o relato dos cronistas mostram que esse
gaúcha era capaz da inclusão do curso dá
a opção da orientação de gênero tão
difícil naquela época ele era capaz
disso era presente lá mas pensa em
talvez seja especulação eu já arriscando
dizer isso mas pensei no que é evidente
eles se comunicavam e convivia com o
português e um espanhol que se matava um
todas as nações e entre os negros e os
piratas
esse é o cara que não passa penal
isso sim é esta o inimigo ao contrário
pode ser esse ano quero que contrariava
éticas importantes daquela época uma
ética de trabalho quando ele dizia estar
processo judicial quando preciso de uma
camisa perto o trabalho quando eu tenho
uma quando ele dizia que contrariava a
ética da propriedade é importante
naquela época
oro dentro da minha camisa debaixo do
chapéu é uma citação a 0
gente
eu não tenho mais condições do que vocês
e dizer sim nós somos assim maniqueísta
e um trabalho da inclusão e do matzá
momento da finalização
eu não sei mas eu sei dizer aquela
referência
eu vou me sentir um elogio
encheu minha roupa de areia para não
viver uma vez porque é uma coisa nessa
figura tem que ser resgatada
como alguém que deu origem a uma cultura
popular que deu origem a um ponto de
vista sim muito reativo rigoroso muito
ético sobre aspectos muito interessante
por exemplo a troca um hit na relação
com os animais
vejam por exemplo aquele menino de 12
anos casado com a jante alemão ea ovelha
tatá da meada para o churrasco de mais
tarde enquanto o pessoal está fazendo
alguma coisa bonita e 12 anos e engloba
volta e diz que gente sem coração deixar
esse animal é verdade
a empresa tap faz diferença ela vai
morrer fácil
tipo de ética
buscar isso não ficar caindo e se foi
de baixo
só isso como ingrediente com a flec
tinha mais pra gente pensar nisso tanto
se fala não parar nós fomos assim por
exemplo a gente pode identificar o
quanto essa radicalidade 20 cita as
revoluções passado está na oligarquia e
não naquele gaúcho acabou sendo
absorvido ou feito desaparecer por essa
linha pelas oligarquias janela mas isso
são só proposta
a frente já está em lei para gerar
seleções
eu quero que você fecha os olhos de novo
eu vou cantar outra vilã pega o cheiro
eu até posso fazer aquela cara assim
muita gente entra e serra um pouco os
olhos e olha a 45 graus
a maior parte das etapas instante eu
canto pra vocês pra agradecer enfim uma
vez mais uma vida longa que talvez não
seja possível talvez a gente pudesse
escutar mesmo pela sua esquisita a tem
que fechar o ano